To get started, let's answer the question,
what is information visualization? Information visualization is
the effective communication of complex quantitative ideas.
This is usually done through geometry and
color. What do we mean by an
effective communication? Well, an effective communication is
the expression of ideas with clarity, precision,
and efficiency. An effective visualization will let
you see things that might go unnoticed if you
didn't visualize the data. Any data set contains tons of
information but you might missed out on trends, behavior
patterns, and dependencies if you don't visualize it. Additionally, an
effective visualization can highlight certain trends in the data
or tell a story to people who might be looking
at the visualization. So why don't we take a look
at an all time classic visualization of information, Charles Minard's
graphical depiction of the terrible fate of
Napoleon's army when they marched on Russia.